This lecture is about the contextual
text mining.
Contextual text mining is related to
multiple kinds of knowledge that we
mine from text data.
As I'm showing here, is related to
topic mining because can make topics
associated with context, like a time or
location, and similarly it can make
opinion mining more contextualized,
making opinions connected to context.
It's related to text based
prediction because it allows us to
combine non text data with text data
to derive sophisticated predictors
for the prediction problem.
So more specifically, why are we
interested in contextual text mining?
Well that's, first,
because text often has rich context
information and this can include
direct context such as meta data.
And also indirect context, so the
direct context can include the meta-data
such as time, location,
authors, and source of the text data.
And they almost always available to us.
Indirect text context refers to
additional data related to the meta
data.
So, for example, from authors, we can
further obtain additional context, such
as social network of the author or the
author's age. And such information is not,
in general, directly related to the text
yet through the authors we can connect
them.
There could be also other text data
from the same source as this one, so
the other context data can be connected
with this text,
as well. So in general, any related
data can be regarded as context, so
there could be remotely related to context.
context.
And so what's the use of,
why is text context useful?
Well, context can be used to
partition text data in many
interesting ways.
It can almost allows partition text
data in arbitrary ways as we need. And
this is very important because this
allows us to do interesting comparative
analysis.
It also in general provides meaning to
the discovery topics if we gonna
associate the text with context.
So here's illustration of how context
can be regarded as interesting ways of
partitioning of text data. So here I
just show some research papers
published in different years.
on different venues, different conference
names here listed on the bottom, like
SIGIR, ACL, etc.
Now, such text data can be partitioning in
many interesting ways because we have
context.
So the context here just includes time
and the conference venues.
And but perhaps we can include some
other variables as well.
But let's see how we can partition data
in interesting ways.
First, we can treat each paper as a
separate unit.
So in this case, a paper ID and each
paper has its own context, it's
independent.
And.
But we can also treat all the papers
written in 1998 as one group, and this
is only possible because of the
availability of time and we can
partition data in this way.
This would allow us to compare topics,
for example in different years.
Similarly, we can partition the data
based on the venues.
We can get all the SIGIR papers and
compare those papers with the rest or
compare SIGIR papers with KDD papers
with ACL papers.
We can also partition the data to
obtain the papers written by authors in
the US, and that of course uses
additional context.
of the authors and this would allow us
to then compare such a subset with
another set of papers written by authors
in other countries.
Or we can obtain a set of papers about
the text mining, and this can be
compared with papers about another topic.
topic.
And note that these partitioning can be
also intersect with each other to
generate even more complicated
partitions.
And so in general, this enables
discovery of knowledge associated with
different context as needed.
And in particular, we can compare
different contexts, and this often
gives us a lot of useful knowledge.
For example, comparing topics overtime,
we can see trends of topics and
comparing topics in different context
can also reveal differences about the
two contexts.
So there are many interesting questions
that require contextual text mining
here, I list some very specific ones.
For example, what topics have been
gaining increasing attention recently
in data mining research?
Now to answer this question, obviously
we need to analyze text in the context
of time.
So time is a context in this case.
Is there any difference in the
responses of people in different
regions to the event, to any event?
So this is a very broad analysis
question, in this case, of course,
location is the context.
What are the common research interests
of two researchers?
In this case, authors can be the
context.
Is there any difference in the research
topics published by authors in the USA
and those outside?
Now, in this case, the context would include
the authors and their affiliation and
location.
So this goes beyond just the author
himself or herself.
We need to look at the additional
information connected to the author.
Is there any difference in the opinions
about the topic expressed on one social
network and another?
In this case, the social network of
authors and the topic can be the
context.
Are there topics in news data that are
correlated with sudden changes in stock
prices?
In this case, we can use a time series
such as stock prices as context.
What issues mattered in the 2012
presidential campaign or presidential
election?
Now in this case, time series again as context.
df
So, as you can see, the list can go on
and on, basically contextual text
mining can have many applications.